heute soll es allerdings nicht um eine
Lüftung gehen meine Damen und Herren die
offensichtlich irgendwie defekt ist
sondern tatsächlich zur Abwechslung
es soll heute tatsächlich endlich mal
wieder
aua aua gestern abend sind wir auf jeden
Fall zurückgekommen aus Amsterdam wurden
noch schön von der Polizei eingehalten
weiß gar nicht warum
[Musik]
Audio ich nehme euch heute tatsächlich
mal wieder 24 Stunden in meinem Alltag
mit und das nicht bei mir hier in meiner
Sauna
in der ich gerade
ich verbringe heute 24 Stunden mit
selfie Sandra
verarschen ne Digger das komplette Licht
ist
wo das sagt jetzt nicht ich habe einen
Stromausfall
irgendwas hat geknackt in der Decke
nicht geht wieder ich verbringe heute 24
Stunden
übrigens ne
und alle die hier sagen ich hätte hier
keine Ahnung irgendwie von ne das ist
hier Glasreiniger tip top
ich verbringe heute 24 Stunden mit
Sandra
das heißt wir frühstücken gleich
zusammen wir nehmen was einkaufen wir
gehen chillen bei ihr wir gehen Podcast
aufnehmen wir gehen bisschen in die
Stadt ich weiß nicht wie das wird aber
danke ich habe mich richtig gekauft habe
so heftig geschissen heute meine Lüftung
ist einfach kaputt gegangen
schön und die Sicherung rausgeflogen
aber Sandra weißt du warum
lässt sich gerade meine Arme
ja wird gefragt Sandra
weißt du warum ich heute mit dir 24
Stunden verbringe nein weil
wir auf der Street six sie haben was das
ist einfach ein drei Meter selfie Stick
und das hier ist die Kamera um die es
heute gehen soll das ist nämlich die
insta 360 X3 seht ihr hier schon drauf
geschrieben in ganz kleines Ding was
aber ganz ganz viel kann Sandra mehr als
du und zwar sieht die schon da vorne
sieht ihr nämlich mich
hallo kann man sie auch runterziehen
dann seht ihr schon es ist wieder ein
kleines Handy das hat unglaublich viele
Funktionen und man kann die auch koppeln
mit der insta 36 die App so dass man
dann auch hier auf dem iPhone oder auf
dem Handy oder was auch immer ihr sehen
könnt haha
hallo und wir beiden Hübschen oder ich
hübscher und die zusammen heute einen
Tag miteinander verbringen 24 Stunden
total super werden wir jetzt erstmal
tatsächlich zum Bäcker gehen
because food is life
[Musik]
ich frühstücke
und Sandra
nachdem wir beiden Süßen jetzt gerade
gefrühstückt haben haben uns hier in
mein Auto gesetzt eigentlich wollte man
mit Sandra Autofahren aber die hat ja
nicht mal einen Führerschein da gibt's
einfach mental und aktiv nicht geschafft
mich weiter an den Führerschein zu
setzen wer hat denn gefragt
[Musik]
wir fahren Einkaufen jetzt in Supermarkt
ja wir fahren Supermarkt super in den
Supermarkt wir gehen jetzt ins Edeka
Center Engels und Sonntag hat gerade
schon gesagt wenn man in solche
Supermärkte geht muss alles strukturiert
wir gehen immer nur bei uns diese
kleinen
[Musik]
hey Leute Ich bin's laserlaka wir waren
jetzt gerade einkaufen wir kochen jetzt
das will der machen ich will was anderes
machen ich will am liebsten hier auf der
Couch liegen wie es warten bis das Essen
fertig ist
und schön
ich glaube wie lange ist dieses
automatische Gerät dieser selfie Stick
der ist einfach invisible also klar man
sieht den jetzt aber wenn du den hältst
mit der Kamera hat ja vorhin schon
gesehen man sieht keinen selfie-stick
das ist so brutal kleine Schneidebrett
für dich und ein großes für mich
egal ja Leute die Sandra menschlich
gesehen ziemlich abstoßen
[Musik]
the food is ready 3 2 1 komm das mache
ich mal so ein richtiger
[Musik]
schöne drohnenshot Aufnahme
sehr gut
so
nein
[Musik]
was zu viel Pfeffer
so viel Salz wir melden uns aufgegessen
haben das Essen war wirklich eine Sand
von zehn von zehn ist die insta 360 x 3
Kamera denn die Aufnahmen von diesem
Ding sind genauso wie die Handhabung
einfach nur genial es ist ein kompaktes
und minimalistisches Design das seht ihr
hier schon feiern wir beide sehr sehr
sehr doll und dann komme ich dazu mit
der App ist so gut wie alles möglich und
eure Kreativität sind einfach fast gar
keine Grenzen mehr Gesetz egal
oder auch wenn ihr damit 360 Grad
Content machen wollte das ist einfach
alles geil und in der Postproduktion
noch einfach zu entscheiden welche
Ausschnitte verwenden wollte wie genau
das alles dargestellt werden soll es
einfach fast genauso cool wie ne
die X3 verfügt außerdem über einen neuen
2,29 Zoll Touchscreen für eine einfache
Bedienung und einen neuen Sensor für
detailreiche Videos und 72 Megapixel
Fotos das ist anders geistiges Alter
weißt du welche Modi zu den neuen Modi
gehören nee ich schon
dann haben wir beispielsweise den 4k 1
Objektiv Modus den 360 active HDR den
ich Modus 8k timeless 4k 12
krass also checkt den ersten Link in der
Infobox ab da kommt ihr zu X3 und wir
haben jetzt Podcast Aufnahme wir sind am
Weihnachtsmarkt angekommen Shelties mit
am Start Sandras mit am Start ich bin
natürlich am Start wir haben Josef Elias
und Eric dahinten wir haben hier einen
krankes Setup aufgebaut nehmen jetzt in
der Podcast Folge auf
meine Damen und Herren und würde den
Block an der Stelle jetzt auch beenden
wenn es euch gefallen hat dann lasst
gern einen Daumen hoch unter dem Video
hier da abonniert meinen Kanal und
klickt auf die Glocke weitere Videos
nicht zu verpassen danke schon an ist
das Rezept das heutige Video
freundlicherweise unterstützt haben
klickt auf den ersten Link unten in der
Videobeschreibung wenn ihr euch mal ein
paar Dinge eure Infos zu dieser Kamera
anschauen wollt sehr sehr geil
komplett kostenlos also kann man nicht
kostet natürlich kann aber auf die
Webseite kostenlos
hört ihr das
der Stromausfall